sûr et efficace deux mots qui pourraient
bien changer la trajectoire du vaccin
russe spoutnik v la revue hebdomadaire
scientifique est respectée zélande 7
dans un coup de projecteur aux
scientifiques russes le développement du
vaccin spoutnik v a été critiquée par sa
précipitation le fait qu'il ait brûlé
les étapes et une absence de
transparence mais les résultats
rapportés ici sont claires et le
principe scientifique de cette
vaccination est démontrée déclarations
de deux spécialistes britanniques a pris
le dernier stade des essais cliniques du
vaccin
la phase 3 qui porte sur près de vingt
mille participants
des essais menés notamment par des
scientifiques indépendants de doses ont
été administrées à trois semaines
d'intervalle et un constat tout nigré
réduit de 91,6 % le risque de contracter
une formes symptomatiques du coc vide
19,97 insiste tout de même sur
l'importance de continuer ses recherches
notamment sur les personnes ne
présentant pas de symptômes
j'estime que c'est effectivement une
réalisations monumentales pour la russie
mais aussi pour le monde entier parce
qu'il n'y a à l'heure actuelle que trois
vaccins dans le monde dont l'efficacité
dépasse 90% unique v et lundi en plus
son efficacité contre les cas graves et
de 100%
c'est donc une réalisation effectivement
très importante et nous sommes
reconnaissants à la revue zealand 7
cela montre qu'elle n'est pas guidée par
des motivations politiques mais par la
science et le désir de faire de la
science de qualité et de trouver une
solution et j'estime donc que c'est une
réussite très importante
satisfaction du côté de moscou et
pression désormais du côté de l' agence
européenne du médicament une demande
d'homologation ya été déposée le 20
janvier
selon le fonds d'investissements directs
russe chargée de commercialiser spoutnik
vais au moins 15 pays se sont tournés
vers la russie
[Musique]
c'est mon fils qui m'a parlé de la
vaccination et j'en étais très heureux
alors je suis venu aussi vite que j'ai
pu au moins cela nous permettra de nous
reposer un peu pour ne plus subir le
stress d'être si prudent toute la
journée
que dieu nous protège de ce fléau
aujourd'hui les boliviens peuvent
respirer tranquillement peuvent
recommencer à vivre lentement et
progressivement la charge centralisée de
vaccins à bruxelles a échoué
cela met en danger la vie des européens
et la relance rapide de l'économie
européenne
c'est pourquoi nous avons cherché de
nouvelles sources d'approvisionnement
nous avons été les premiers mais il est
peu probable que nous soyons les seuls
dans l'union européenne à participer à
cet effort
même soulagement pour le kazakhstan le
fonds d'investissements directs russe
promet qu'il peut fournir à l'union
européenne 100 millions de doses de son
vaccin pour 50 millions de personnes au
deuxième trimestre 2021
ce mardi la chancelière angela merkel a
informé que tous les vaccins autorisés
seront les bienvenues en allemagne